The MRI scanner was invented in 1977, and
it's revolutionized medical diagnostics.
Short for magnetic resonance imaging, an MRI
offers an inside look at the human body
without surgery or x rays.
When investigating health problems, it's a
great way to get the picture.
Using magnetic fields and radio wave pulses,
an MRI can look right through you to
determine what's going on under your skin.
The magnet is incredibly powerful.
It's up to 30,000 times stronger than the
Earth's magnetic field.
To make an MRI scanner.
They weld aluminum casing around the magnet,
creating a tunnel in the center for the
patient. The seams must be extremely tight
because the tube will also contain the super
cold liquid helium, which will make the
magnet so incredibly powerful.
Once the welds are complete, they cap the
magnet and transfer it to a test chamber.
They pump helium gas into the tube and
activate a vacuum system that sucks out the
air in the chamber.
A sensor confirms there are no leaks and the
welds are tight.
They now construct a second aluminum tube
around the magnet.
This will act as an insulating shield.
They wrap an aluminum mylar blanket tightly
around the magnet.
Aluminum mylar was first developed as an
insulating material for spacesuits.
In this case, it'll be used to deflect heat
to keep the magnet cold.
They now insert the magnet into a steel
shell.
This is known as the vacuum vessel because
air will be pulled from the space between it
and the magnet, creating a vacuum which will
serve as another insulator.
They mask the tunnel with plastic and spray
paint the exterior white.
The paint will protect the steel from rust.
Next, they install a refrigeration unit
known as a cold head.
The cold head will maintain the helium
around the MRI's primary magnet at the
incredibly chilly temperature of -269
degrees Celsius.
This will keep the helium in a liquid state
without the cold head.
Significant amounts would vaporize and be
lost.
They now pump the liquid helium into the
magnet.
It's one of the coldest things on the
planet.
And the film nozzles turn frosty.
Exposed to this extreme cold, the magnet
loses all electrical resistance and becomes a
superconductor, generating intense magnetic
fields.
With the MRI magnet complete, they move on
to the gradient coil, which will control the
orientation of the image with electrical
pulses.
It starts with a fiberglass epoxy tube cut
to the correct length.
A worker carves grooves in the tube and
fills those grooves with epoxy.
So he then winds copper wire into the epoxy
field grooves and it adheres forming the
gradient coil.
The team slathers epoxy onto the entire
tube.
The epoxy seals the wire preventing
vibrations of the coil when it's in
operation. They layer etched copper plates
onto the epoxy and they adhere.
They wrap the coil tightly with Teflon
cloth.
A worker pours epoxy resin onto the fabric.
He then winds tubing around the gradient
coil and it adheres to the epoxy coated
cloth. These are cooling lines.
They'll disperse heat generated by the
gradient coil.
Another worker now preps the next fiberglass
tube.
This one is for the MRIs radio frequency
coil.
There's much more to come before this MRI's
scanner is ready to provide an inside look at
the human body.
Work on the MRIs.
Radiofrequency coil is underway.
A technician attaches plastic risers and
pads to the fiberglass core.
The risers and pads will hold the circuitry
parts at a uniform level.
She applies adhesive backed strips of copper
from one band of risers to the other.
These copper strips are the antenna.
They'll send and receive signals from the
body and relay them to a computer to produce
the MRI image.
She presses the copper with a round tip tool
for better adhesion to the core.
She then dabs epoxy glue into the riser
compartments.
She inserts capacitors into the glue filled
These little capacitors will store energy
and change the frequency of the coil to match
the magnets. The technician sorters the ends
of the capacitors to the copper antenna as
she builds the circuitry.
She transfers numerous high voltage inductor
boards to the pads and screws them in place.
Next up, our cable splitter units.
Another technician installs one near an
inductor board.
She routes some of the cables from the
splitter to several of the inductors.
And she solders the cables to the inductors.
She places a plastic cable track on the side
of the radio frequency coil and snakes the
main power cable through it.
She saw it as the cable to the antenna.
The technician stiffens the copper antenna
with composite boards to dampen vibrations
when the mry is in operation.
She applies epoxy around all the cables.
The epoxy secures the cables to keep them
from moving around and making noise.
The MRI is radio frequency coil is complete
and ready to be put to the test.
The next worker caps the ends with metal
domes and bolts them tightly to it.
She pumps highly pressurized air into the
capped radio frequency coil.
She sprays soapy water over the exterior of
the coil and looks for air bubbles.
Bubbles in the soapy residue would indicate
a leak that would disrupt airflow in the dry.
With the radiofrequency coil leak free.
They now slide it into the gradient coil,
which has gained an outer fiberglass shell
since we last saw it.
The worker connects exterior tubing to the
network of cooling lines inside the gradient
coil. With those connections made, they're
ready to assemble the coils to the magnet.
The worker slides the assembly off the cart
and into the MRI magnet.
He installs a bracket that centers the
coils, maintaining a small gap between them
and the magnet. He equips the Maasai with
microphones and speakers to communicate with
the patient. There's also a signaling system
here for the patient to activate in the event
of an emergency. Now for the ultimate test.
They energise the magnet and send standard
test objects into the MRI.
They scan the objects and confirm that the
picture is clear.
They add a metal and plastic outer casing.
This MRI's scanner is now ready to focus on
diagnosis.
The next picture it takes could be a life
saver.